well let's get some more detail now on
the military situation in and around
taiwan with the chief executive of civil
line and the security expert justin
crump justin it's great to have you here
just bring us up to date with what's
happening around taiwan yeah absolutely
so we're on day three
of four days of announced chinese
exercises
um
essentially in response to speaker
pelosi's visit but actually i think the
scale of these as we just indicated from
the report
shows these have probably been some time
in the planning
and they actually fit with the pattern
of increased chinese activity towards
taiwan we've been seeing over the last
couple of years
so effectively a pretext for a large
scale
chinese demonstration or rehearsal
of their potential capability to take
the island so that's what we've been
seeing over these few days the first day
in particular saw missile launches the
mainland that probably is something that
china brought forward and hadn't
necessarily planned before and that did
include one missile flying over the
island which is obviously very
provocative that hasn't happened before
missiles landing around the island a
naval blockade simulated with areas and
the exercise area is very close to the
island itself in the shipping lanes
and much closer than we've seen hitherto
so all simulating uh what we'd expect in
the event of a war and that included
cyber blockades trade blockades
sanctions
all of those things been put in place
and if we zoom in
we can see a little bit about what the
provocative actions look like so the big
box is the taiwanese air defense
identification zone that syria they
defend of their airspace
it's actually in practice divided by
what's called the median line which cuts
off this part of it so that's that's
what taiwan's interested in
and so chinese ships and aircraft been
deliberately crossing the median line
flying either side of the island
circumnavigating the island and
simulating strikes against u.s carrier
groups
that would otherwise intervene in the
conflict so we've seen all that going on
over three days today seems to have seen
a rehearsal for an amphibious assault
what that would look like going to the
median line only and turning back but
just effectively stepping across and and
showing that to taiwan and so i wouldn't
be surprised if tomorrow sees the
conclusion of the exercises with some
land-based
simulations of combat to demonstrate
what the fighting would look like on the
island now real war would take a lot
more than four days but basically china
going through the motions uh with all of
that currently and if we talk just very
quickly about those drones because
they've aroused a lot of interest these
are actually islands belonging to taiwan
but they're very close in
to the chinese coast and if you zoom in
you can actually see how close they are
so we think of the island but actually
taiwan has has territory literally a
mile and a half off
the mainland um and this routinely
actually gets buzzed by these sorts of
smaller drones with surveillance
capabilities so um that's happening
often but they've increased the tempo uh
towards that and again you're seeing
this sort of action around the island by
chinese aircraft
just to kind of simulate that war
fighting thing and send that message to
taiwan justin it's great to get your
thoughts thank you very much indeed
thank you thank you